well in the United States more and more
people are realizing that there's a
rising tide of acceptance in the fact
that people are going to smoke marijuana
and it's like prohibition against
alcohol back in the 1930s there's a
recognition that perhaps the laws are
causing more harm than the drugs they're
designed to protect us from I believe
the name of the conference is the final
days of prohibition marijuana has been
prohibited federally for 75 years now
December 5th is going to be the
anniversary of the repeal of alcohol
prohibition and we plan on at SSCP we
plan on celebrating that by calling on
politicians around the globe to revisit
this failed policy of prohibiting drugs
I think that the time is near when we're
going to see a big shift toward allowing
states to determine their own policies
you know we have more than half the
country now supports ending marijuana
prohibition to have so much public
support for reform while the same time
the federal government is cracking down
speaks to the incredible disconnect
between the federal government and the
people we can't translate that into
votes in Congress there are seven bills
pending in Congress to reform marijuana
laws in one form or another we can't
even get a subcommittee hearing the
states are really where all the action
is it's kind of exciting because 2012 is
the year that Washington state Colorado
and Oregon all have initiatives to do
different degrees of legalized tax and
regulate marijuana if those states pass
in a number of weeks from now when the
election occurs it will change the world
it will really change the world and it
might also change the way things are
done federally as far as the upcoming
elections throughout the country I feel
that two out of the three states
a valid shot it's unfortunate that
polling does not reflect great news for
Oregon
however Colorado has and even
even-steven chances I believe much like
prop 19 they have to be cautious for
their October Surprise but they can come
through and they've got a great base in
Colorado in Colorado
you know the marijuana initiative is
pulling better than either the
presidential candidates right now and
you know I think that that's really
telling in Washington State
I think we're pulling at 58% and I think
we've got unprecedented amount of
mainstream important people in our
communities endorsing us I think if
Washington does legalize that it's an
excellent opportunity to actually bring
this issue to the forefront we have a
state that's willing to stand up for its
electorate and frankly that's exactly
what we needed well I think California
still remains both at the vanguard
culturally and is the big enchilada
politically because if it legalizes
marijuana I think the United States does
and then I think most of Western Europe
and the rest of the world that wants to
go in that direction those folks that
that support support ending prohibition
need to call their members of Congress
need to call the White House need to get
active need to push the agenda forward
that's the way we're going to push
political change just like any other
movement